the jurogan experience i was working at
uh warner brothers
uh tiny toon adventures and i was a
i was a i was a pa production assistant
at that time was the first job i ever
had in la and
that guy says uh hey we're gonna have a
party tonight we're gonna watch these
fights they're like [ __ ] fights
come on over let's watch them and i went
over this house and i was literally
hypnotized watching royce gracie do what
he did
i couldn't believe it everybody else was
talking 93
their first the very first the first ufc
it was the first one
wow so you you watched the first one
live yeah i saw it
at a party that i was not supposed to be
at and
nobody else was paying attention to this
it was just on it was like two other
guys watching it
and uh and i'm watching this going i
gotta do that like
it was speaking to me in a way i've
never you know like art speaks to me and
i was watching it and and the next day i
i find torrance gracie academy because
they kept saying torrence gracie and i
knew where torrance was so
i i was living in the studio city
in the valley i drove i had a honda
prelude i drove all the way on the 405
the worst freeway in the world and took
about three hours to get down there on a
saturday morning
and i walked into that place and it was
they were done but i could smell all
that
sweat and humidity and nastiness and i
was like oh god this is great
i walked in and and they were very nice
to me but there was like these dudes and
they looked so intimidating and they
were just ripped up and clawed up and
dripping wet
this wasn't the pretty days where
everybody has rash guards and designer
ghees this is like
krogan's ghees yup they were yellowed
and nasty smelling
and and no there was no there was chest
hair in your mouth i remember krogan's
and uh and and they came walking out and
i was just like i felt
man i felt like a little [ __ ] i was
just looking at him going like i want to
be
you and he goes uh where are you from
you know and i'll go oh the valley of
the valley
this is too far my friend and he goes uh
my cousins jean-jacques is in the valley
the machados go there and uh i was kind
of like
struck and awe by everything right so i
thought
okay i'll go to the valley you know and
there was no internet never understand
there's no internet you can't just
google so i got the thomas guide out and
i started looking around and
and i was asked people and and so nobody
knew the answer to this because remember
as you know in the early days brazilian
jiu jitsu was like oh you do that karate
stuff
yeah and so i uh i got on my mountain
bike i was a heavy mountain biker then
and i got on my bike and i was in studio
city and i decided to ride ventura
boulevard
and i'm gonna look at every shop on
ventura boulevard and i was driving i
got all the way down to encino
and uh and just and i see this jiu jitsu
right and i go oh that's it i walk in
and this little kind of chubby round guy
comes walking up and it's
tucked into his ghee and he goes i can
help you and i go
i'm looking to do uh i'm looking to do
that ground fighting stuff
and he goes yeah we do that here and i
go
okay you know sign up and so i signed up
and i'm there a week and i'm there every
day and not once are we on the ground
we're doing the stand up
small circle stuff and like and i'm
looking at my classmates
and they're all like horribly out of
shape and like
they can barely move and i'm thinking
god this isn't what i saw what was the
place
it was like moo shin roo jiu jitsu right
but i was so
out of my head trying to find it and so
i'm there a week
and he's like hey congratulations you
get a belt and i'm like
i hardly know anything and say give me
this belt and i'm working on this one
guy
and he says hey i think what you want is
the machados and i was like
where am i because this isn't it dude
and i'm like in the wrong movie and so
i go okay uh he goes that's down the
road dude like
four stores four shops four shops short
right
so i literally at class i'm like
hurrying up and i'm like i gotta go
and i walk down there and i see them and
this is on ventura boulevard
he wasn't at his place in tarzana yet he
was
getting ready to move that week and i
walk in and it was a place as big as
this studio not kidding
and he goes you know john jack spoke
very poorly english back then and he was
like oh hello hello
and i'm like uh sign i sign up now you
know
so i signed up and i started going to
him but i had made like two
friends say i went in l.a i didn't have
any friends i was there to work and
become
my goal and so uh i was still talking to
these guys and still going to the other
place and the time worked out where he
was early and i would leave and go next
door to john jock
right so i was there about another week
and we're just doing drills at john jox
we're doing armbar drills over and over
again from our back
from open guard drills and i would go
home and i would draw it in my book i
had a sketchbook of everything so
everything
we learned i would draw it and i would
you know i was an animator for a long
time so
i could animate the movements and i
could see enrolling
where we would end up so if we start
here and i did this this and this
i knew we would end up over here in this
position in my mind it was easy because
i had to animate it
so i would see rolling like cartoons and
they would just kind of roll into it
and so it came very i wasn't a wrestler
but it came pretty natural to me to
the movements right and so um
so a week later the guy at the
mushin room jiu jitsu place was telling
me
oh you got to do this because and i go
but if you did that you get stuck in an
arm bar
because he's having me like choke like
reach up and he goes no
you can't get a number from there and i
go i think i think you can
he's like you're not gonna do it and so
i i go well watch and he got in my guard
and he like he did his little chest lap
thing you know those little like
and and he like stuck his arm out
where's the little chest truck yeah you
know how they like get ready to fight
and they're like
you know they do their poses and he did
that
in my guard and it was weird and
everybody's watching
right and they're standing there
watching the instructor tell me i didn't
know what i was doing
and he did that and he stuck his arm out
and i grabbed his arm and i pulled it in
and i threw my legs over his face and i
bought him and he got real pissed off
and he goes he got up and he was really
perturbed and he goes
that wouldn't work in real time that
only worked because i was letting you
get there and i
and i was scared and i go i think it
would work man
i think it would work and remember i had
two friends now right
my two guy friends right right i think
and they were going and i hear one of
them go
oh no it worked and i'm looking over at
him and he's getting kind of pissed man
he's a short guy but he's really stuck
and he goes uh he goes look i'm tired of
hearing about this
brazilian jiu jitsu so i tell you what
you use your jiu jitsu which by the way
i had had like two weeks
of training now granted i was there
every day with janja like doing
drills so you know if you got one
movement that you do
a hundred times you're gonna have an
inkling of how to do it
what year is this bro so you're talking
about
94 right after the first ufc maybe like
two months after the first ufc also the
93 yeah 93.
and so we're ahead of the curve so i'm
sitting there and i go okay
uh i think i think it'll work dude now i
don't know anything about standing right
right so he gets up and he goes okay i'm
going to attack you
and you attack me and i'm like i don't
know how to attack you so he goes
he goes he goes he goes ready and like
all of a sudden i'm in a video game
and i'm standing there so what do i do i
copy what i saw boys gracie do
i stick my arms up like the karate kid
and i stick my foot in front
and he [ __ ] starts like like coming
at me with his elbows and swinging and
he looks like a little machine
and i just took my foot and kicked him
in the front leg his leg goes down he
lands on me we fall under the guard he
starts hitting me with his elbow on the
top of the head
right like i grabbed him i clenched him
i squeezed him really tight
mostly so i didn't get punched in the
face because i was afraid
and and i took my head in his chest and
he's hitting me on the top of the head
and i'm like
and that heat comes up your back from
your butthole to your neck and you go
you [ __ ] you're hitting me now
and i go okay all right all right now
we're in a new league now you're not my
friend
now you're fighting me and i literally
just kind of monkey
shimmied up his high guard and i just
threw him in an arm bar and i cranked as
hard as i could on that arm and he
screams
okay wow and i get up right and i'm like
you got that blood rush i'm like hair
messed
a [ __ ] and i
and i grab my bag i grab my bag my
little [ __ ] goofy bag
i grab it and i walk out right i'm like
i don't know what to do
i'm like flustered i walk out and the
two dudes come running out after me
they're like bro bro i'm coming with you
where you going where's that school at
and they came and they [ __ ] trained
all the way to purple belt both those
guys who were the guys it was jim lahan
the wood carpenter guy and a guy named
seth
i don't even remember his last name they
both trained all the way through purple
before they kind of faded away
and uh and man you fade away when you're
at purple that's such a shame you're so
close
as an instructor now it crushes me when
i give a blue belt to someone and then i
see them fade and i'm thinking
god dude you got past the harness you're
a color
yeah the greatest belt you can get is
blue yeah
i say that it's to this day and i'm
fourth black blue because you're a color
you're not the white anymore you're in
the club you're in
dude the day john jock gave me a blue
belt was like one of the greatest days
of my life
the day john jack gave me my purple belt
i was like oh my god i'm
close i'm so close to brown purple is a
danger
purple belts tap people so i remember
seeing a lot of purple belts that could
tap brown belts oh yeah purple because
they were dangerous they had like one
really good move oh yeah
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download
episodes to save on data cost all for
free
spotify is absolutely free you don't
have to have a premium account to watch
new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify
app go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience